[Musique]
zibeline meta est une légende bien
vivante de la musique classique de
passage à la maison symphonique il se
souvient que pour lui tout a commencé à
l'orchestré symphonique de montréal you
know un mauvais sentiment son poste
istat hier in the life of jobs marc
forceville homme affable et
get me out of my head
mais à bombay en inde d'un père
violoniste zubin mehta est devenu le
directeur musical de l'osce m en 1961 il
avait à peine 24 en 1963 il a participé
à l'inauguration de la toute nouvelle
salle wilfrid pelletier de la place des
arts il a dirigé l'orchestré lors des
deux première tournée européenne de son
histoire it was not des orchestres of
today
la carrière de zubin mehta s'est envolé
après son départ de montréal en 1967 il
a dirigé entre autres l'orchestré
philharmonique de los angeles jusqu'en
1978 et puis celui de new york jusqu'en
1991 et pendant 50 ans il a donné quatre
mille concerts avec l'orchestré
philharmonique d'israël dont un premier
concert en allemagne en 1971 everybody
inscrits et
rogers
[Musique]
de passage à montréal pour
l'enregistrement de concert avec le sm à
85 ans zubin mehta est encore loin de
penser à la retraite et canal d'image
dépôt à musique à
tout prix people together
people goût à la vie tchad à oreille
giada à la toute fin de notre entretien
le maestro n'a pu s'empêcher de nous
confier qu'il est encore tout jeune et
qu'il n'a aucune limite à bayonne mène
ici wifi depuis mai radio canada morin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]